- I cannot wait to see you!
Alright, see you soon, bye.
- Hey, do you wanna go to Lauren's party
with me on Saturday?
- Oh, I just made plans with your Mom.
(upbeat music)
- No one's liked my status yet,
will you like it?
- Yeah.
- [Ali] Thanks.
- It's not funny though.
Hey, I'm using your curling iron!
It's freezing in here.
- [Ali] It is so hot!
- [Lily] Are you freaking kidding me,
it's freezing!
Do you wanna come to San Diego
with my whole family at
the end of the month?
- To visit Uncle Jack?
- [Lily] Yup.
- Oh my God yes, I miss him!
- He misses you too, he
was talking about you.
Mom?
Ok this is for you.
- [Both] Happy Birthday!
- Love you, Gina!
- It's me and Ali, we love you!
- Your Dad just liked 14
of my Facebook statuses.
- Hey, I'm up.
Are you up?
- No.
- C'mon, let's go to brunch.
- It is so bright out, it's so early!
- It's not early, it's 10.
- Lily?
I'm just coming to get that red shirt.
- We're going.
- Why are you making me
go to brunch before noon?
- [Lily] People go to brunch at 10.
- Nobody goes to brunch at 10!
- Hey, I'm using your bronzer.
Hey, I'm using your deoderant.
You look really good in this picture.
- Oh thank you!
- Did you borrow my shirt?
- Yeah I came over to get it
last week with the spare key.
- Also your Mom looks amazing.
- But he said, "Well what are
you doing tonight instead?"
- Oh that's great.
- [Ali] And I said, "I don't
know, I don't have any plans.
"I'm currently laying in my
bed spooning a bag of chips."
- Wait, did you already send that?
You have to run all your texts
by me before you press send.
What are you doing?
- [Ali] I'm turning left.
- No, we're gonna be going...
I thought we were going straight!
Go straight, what are you...
go straight!
If he wanted to go on a date with you,
I think you would know by now.
- That's it, and if he wanted
to go on a date with me,
he would go on a date with me!
- You're like giving him
too much of what he wants.
You keep texting him.
You have to do what I
do, just be like, "Hey."
And then they respond
and then you don't
answer for like six days.
Hey, I'm using your toothbrush.
- You're beautiful.
- You're beautiful!
- I miss your Mom.
Do you ever think about when we grow older
how we should get houses
next to each other
and, you know, have kids,
and they can be best friends?
- Yes!
Except in my fantasy,
they grow up and they fall in love,
and they get married,
and then we get to be like in-laws.
- Oh my God, and then
they could have kids,
and then you and I can
be the best grandmas.
- The coolest grandmas.